there was this thing you may remember
some of you may remember this those of
you who've really been paying attention
there was this thing called covid for a
while this is where people were wrapping
their heads in cellophane and staying in
underground bunkers and ordering in
chinese takeout for a while because you
had to do that to make sure grandma
didn't die um well there was this guy
anthony fauci from the nih i represent
science and uh he's been a public
servant for a couple decades now uh
unclear how much he's done that's ever
been good it's very unclear actually and
a lot of people think he's done an awful
lot of bad um and he's lied to us many
times over and he could be in a lot of
trouble if the republicans take congress
again as uh my friend rand paul has
already pointed out they will try to
drag him in and actually break up the
position and and i know he could face
all sorts of punishment but anyway
here's anthony fauci a few days after
the 2020 election november 12th to be
precise so this is right after biden won
the election uh when fauci decided to
really tell us who's in charge
so are there countries that you you know
they're countries that seem to be doing
well that then weren't doing so are
there countries now that hold up as
models for
you know pretty good response to this
you know the answer is yes but right now
it seems that every country is suffering
we are often compared with countries
that are not comparable to us we are not
a little island of five million people
that we can shut off
we're not a country that would accept if
a ruler tells us you must do this i was
talking with our uk colleagues
just today
who were saying the uk is very similar
to where we are now an outbreak because
each of our countries have that
independent spirit but we don't want to
be told what to do
well i understand that but now is the
time to do
what you're told
and i think it really is something that
we should be doing right now
the laugh right it's the laugh after now
is the time to do what you're told like
man you just scratch one of these people
you scratch a government worker you
scratch a lefty a progressive and the
worst sort of tyrannical authoritarian
just comes out and it's so interesting
because that which also feels like a
really long time ago but it's only a
year and a half ago right after the
election of 2020
um
you can see the way it shifted where
he's actually talking about freedom
there are some things that we can't do
there's the streak of independence uh
we are he says we are not a country who
would accept that you will do this
meaning that will accept mandates and
lockdowns and everything else and then
he pushed the hell out of mandates which
now are disappearing because good
american people fought back against it
but that was a year and a half ago uh
now that uh kovitz seems to be wrapping
up although season two is coming i'm
pretty sure of that uh here's fauci a
couple days ago
and he's uh he's digging the the
lockdowns and all the other stuff and
maybe they will make a comeback if we do
see
a significant surge particularly one
that might result in increased
hospitalizations we have to be prepared
to pivot and perhaps reinstitute some of
those restrictions
no anthony we are not reinstituting
those restrictions you are not the god
of us you are not an elected official
and i think there's an argument to be
made that even the elected officials
don't have the right to lock our
businesses and keep us in our homes and
enter everything else
and thankfully i live in the free state
of florida and i know that the governor
here will not listen to any of your
nonsense and we have a surgeon general
here latipo who's actually following the
science